and we will continue taking calls at 6 1
7 8 3 0 47 50 we will go let's go to 6 3
6 who's there from 6 3 6 hi David
this is Noah I wanted to ask you a
question about the election system
because when I made my first vote I felt
like it was knowing void what in what
way well I had two other options I saw
that Hillary she was the only choice I
could go with I'm guessing you had to do
the same after it was between Bernie or
Hillary so you're are you let's see if
we can back up just just a little bit
here now so I understand what you're
saying are you talking about your vote
in the presidential election in November
of 2016
yes I'm 20 I'm talking about 2016 elects
presidential election I don't like after
that first vote what kind of deterred so
you're saying that you went to let's see
fighters so you woke up on November
whatever date it was 2016 you went to
vote and the people on the ballot were
Trump Hillary Jill Stein the libertarian
guy who's really not Gary Johnson or you
could write someone in and you had what
issue I had an issue with how much it
felt like we were choosing between
between the worst of two political
represents for our country okay
and so your question is my question is
just being stuck with either one I had
to choose the party that my beliefs can
with which is that we need equality for
everyone okay and that we need to get
the system more workable for everyone
who suffered during this time last few
years right okay is so is there is there
maybe there isn't a question like were
you just calling to comment I was
les had two questions in mine first that
was just something them reminder more or
less to keep myself thinking about
politics okay guys good good the first
question is is there a way to go back to
the Australian ballot because that
seemed more like it would be a more
efficient way of voting mm-hmm because
about system we have now when you put in
machine machine could screw up or
something where it can basically
register your ballot as somebody else is
like a Republican Democrat or Green
Party or whatever
no well listen I really appreciate the
call I think you're bringing up just
such important issues and it's really
great that you're thinking about this
stuff unfortunately they're so
wide-ranging that I wouldn't I don't
know why that I can do justice to them
is the way I would say it but listen
voting is great and and and we want a
system that works for people I'm still
wondering who know Noah voted for
through it I think he voted for Hillary
I think he have no choice but to vote
for Hillary although he said he voted
for the party he least stands with I
didn't I didn't totally get that but
clear I think it's listen he voted and I
think that we can all be very very glad
about